-Welcome back!
-Thank you! Wow!
-It's lovely to have you back.
You and Rosie are friends.
You know each other.
-Yes, we are.
-We are friends.
We were on the ill-fated --
I don't know --
season whatever of "The View."
And Donald Trump is
our through line.
So, he came out, and she was
supposed to fight with me.
And she said, "He's a racist."
And I was like, "Mm-hmm."
And then she -- "He's terrible."
I was like, "Mm-hmm."
And that was it.
We both got fired.
Right?
-Yes, pretty much.
-I want to ask about --
There's so many things
I want to ask you about.
But the shutdown --
it seems like everyone is in
agreement, pretty much.
There's maybe some
far-right holdouts
that Trump won this game.
But everybody seems to agree
that Nancy Pelosi
played this perfectly.
What do you think is the fallout
from this for the president?
-Well, the fallout is --
those far-right holdouts
are calling us, you know,
from blocked numbers,
saying, "Yeah, he lost."
I mean, the holdout is --
even the wackiest part
of his base thinks he's a giant
loser for this whole caper.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No, seriously.
And it's not because
they disagree about the wall.
They just think that,
strategically, he failed.
They think that he was owned
publicly and privately
by Nancy Pelosi.
And it's sort of an
insider point,
but it was his
son-in-law, Jared Kushner,
who ran point on this.
And they think he's not
up for the task
of running legislative affairs
for The White House.
-She seemed, at every level, to
know exactly what to do.
Was the taking away of the
State of the Union --
Was taking away something
that ceremonial
from the president
a stroke of genius from Nancy?
-It's a mistake to project onto
him more sophistication
than exists, and for him,
taking away air time,
taking away the thing
that we all recognize
from the movies and whatnot
about being president,
standing there with
the people behind you
clapping or booing
or whatever they're doing.
That, to him --
Those are some of the most
sort of powerful
and precious things to him
about being president.
So to take that away
really did sort of
cut all of his leverage.
-And, of course,
it's happening on the same day
that he capitulates there,
Roger Stone is indicted.
You traveled in
Republican circles
when he was in those circles,
as well, Roger Stone.
What was your take on
Roger Stone?
-I mean, he was at a firm
that was so dirty,
you just knew that if no one
else would hire a bad dictator,
like, "Oh, well,
that firm will do it."
It was Stone, Manafort,
who's awaiting sentencing
for his felonies.
And, you know, the idea that
we're all supposed to believe --
Chris Christie
was on my show today,
and I said, "You know,
everyone around the president
has either been convicted
or is awaiting trial
for the crime of
lying about Russia.
Is that a coincidence?"
"Eh, it might be a coincidence."
I mean, everyone that
the president
surrounded himself with
is either
a convicted felon or
has been charged with a felony.
-You talked to Chris Christie
today, and it was a very long --
You talked to him
for about 40 minutes,
and it was
a fascinating interview.
-I don't think it
was that long, was it?
-No, I was -- But, again,
I wanted to hear you
interview him.
But, you know,
he wrote this book,
and it seems to be a thing
that a lot of people
leave the Trump administration,
and then they take this
one shot at sort of
reframing their experience,
because they are now
trying to, you know,
re-enter polite society.
Do you think Chris Christie will
be effective with this book,
with his take on
what had happened
inside that White House?
-I think Chris Christie
is like Donald Trump,
in that people know
what they think about him.
And if you're from
New Jersey, you know,
he left with some of
the lowest approval ratings
in that state's history.
But I think if you're in
the Republican Party
and you see a lot of people
were into Trump,
Chris Christie has some of that
bluntness without, you know,
all of the criminality that
seems to follow Donald Trump.
-Well, I do think
something that's similar
with the two of them is they --
The people were charmed
by their authenticity.
You know, and, again,
it was no small thing
that Chris Christie
was, you know,
a Republican governor
in New Jersey.
-Yeah. And, look, Chris Christie
has genuine friendships
on the other side of the aisle.
And I don't want to
name any of them.
They may be in witness
protection at this point.
But, I mean, he did --
-"I got the kind of friends that
don't like the world knowing."
-No, no. But he -- And has
obvious political talents.
The challenge I think
he'll have with the book is --
he savages Jared Kushner,
the president's son-in-law.
He spares nothing.
And Kushner deserves it.
Savages Bannon.
Bannon deserves it.
I said this to him on TV,
so don't feel like
I'm talking about him behind
his back on TV.
But he doesn't lay a glove,
really, on the president.
And the president puts those
incompetent and
seemingly corrupt people
in very powerful places.
-Yeah, I guess that's
the disconnect is --
how can you say it's not
the president's fault?
He's surrounded by, you know,
sort of liars and idiots,
because that seems to be,
like, a pretty important part
of the job is who you bring into
The White House with you.
-The president has surrou--
There weren't any qualifications
to work on the Trump campaign
or you didn't really
have to know how to do
anything political.
-Yeah.
-But you had to know Russians,
like Russians,
and then lie about
what you did with them.
-Yeah.
That's a weird thing to have.
That's -- You had that in
"special skills" on the résumé.
-Maybe it was, like -- Yeah...